today is Donald Trump's first full day
as the 45th President of the United
States
this morning the president is waking up
after spending his first night in the
White House after being sworn into
office on Friday the President and First
Lady Melania Trump attended three
inaugural balls last night including one
honoring the military but it was not all
a celebration more than two hundred
anti-trump demonstrators were arrested
during a day of protest in Washington
some set fires or threw bricks into
windows of businesses a second day of
demonstrations is expected today as tens
of thousands will gather for the women's
march on Washington Nancy Cordes is at
the Capitol where Donald Trump took the
oath of office Nancy good morning good
morning and there is no question it is
the dawn of a new era Donald Trump woke
up yesterday morning in the president's
guest house as a billionaire who had
never held public office he is waking up
today in the White House as the most
powerful man in the world hail to the
chief greeted the President and First
Lady at last night's first inaugural
ball
they were joined onstage during the
inaugural danced by the vice president
and mrs. pence and the Trump family mr.
Trump posed this question to an audience
of revelers should I keep the Twitter
going or not
keep it going the late-night
celebrations capped a day of tradition
it began at the historic st. John's
Episcopal Church a block from the White
House while mr. Trump was there the 44th
president left a note in the Oval Office
for the 45th then mr. Trump and his wife
Melania crossed Pennsylvania Avenue to
the White House and mrs. Trump presented
a gift to Michelle Obama after coffee
and tea mr. Obama and mr. Trump rode
together from the White House to the
Capitol where members of Congress were
waiting along with the nation's 8th
Supreme Court justices a bipartisan
group of former presidents and mr.
Trump's opponent a former First Lady
Hillary Clinton Chief Justice John
Roberts swore in the new president just
before news so help me God
so help me God greeted with a 21-gun
salute the president made it clear
change had arrived in Washington the
time for empty talk is over now arrives
the hour of action on the National Mall
supporters savored the speech but I hope
we can do at least half of what he said
he thinks he can do her tradition now
former President Obama and his wife
Michelle boarded a military chopper
after the ceremony taking one last look
at the White House before flying to
Andrews Air Force Base at the Capitol
president Trump signed bills formally
nominating members of his cabinet
and at a lunch in his honor mr. Trump
tried to set a unifying talent there is
something that I wanted to say because I
was very honored very very honored when
I heard that President Bill Clinton and
Secretary Hillary Clinton was coming
today and I think it's appropriate to
say and I'd like you to stand up I'd
like you to stand down
[Applause]
and then the parade the new first family
followed a well-worn route to the White
House
lined mostly with supporters but there
were pockets of detractors too the
family arrived at the reviewing stand a
little behind schedule and after a
jam-packed day sat together to take it
all in the president then took a break
from the festivities to sign an
executive order in the Oval Office
instructing government agencies to begin
lifting requirements related to
Obamacare a move he had vowed to make on
day one the relevant agencies and
Congress are now trying to figure out
exactly what that means it appears that
this order releases the agencies from
any responsibilities of imposing the
costs associated with Obamacare like the
individual mandate that requires all
Americans Alex to buy insurance Nancy
Cordes at the Capitol thanks Nancy